what's a funeral it's about an hour it
tends to be in the morning the rest of
the day is your own
i don't want you to judge me ladies and
gentlemen when my nana died
we went bowling
you know life goes on not hers obviously
she was in a box on fire
i was on fire three strikes
one final custom that we have in ireland
regarding death on a funeral
is that only one person
who is buried in a graveyard can go to
heaven
which basically means if two people are
buried
in the same graveyard on the same day
the last one in
has got to wait till tomorrow
so can you imagine what would happen if
one funeral met another funeral
going to the same graveyard
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
that's right man you're gonna want to
come to my funeral
i'm gonna put the fun in funeral
to be hard to be sad i got a big bowl of
candy on my chest
that is gonna help some people man
people walking by my casket i can't
believe you're gone i
can't believe smarties oh my god
i love smarties somebody takes two
pieces i grabbed their arms
come on
come to my funeral man there's gonna be
dancing man i'm having music and a dj
just throw your hands in the air and
wave them like it ain't in there
[Applause]
oh come to my funeral man it's gonna be
great there's gonna be a mosh pit
and don't just let me lay there
get me involved pick me up let me crowd
surf
you're like man you go to hawkins
funeral yeah it was locked up
i recently listened to your segment
about the lawyer
and the top five dumbest questions he
was ever asked
i thought it was awesome and i thought
you should have some
here's some of my stories and questions
i have experienced working in the
funeral industry
in the last eight years the top here we
go ladies and gentlemen the top
dumbest questions have been
number one have you ever considered
having sex with a dead person
definitely not considering most of them
look like your grandmother
i get this question a lot maybe it is a
fair question but i think 99
of most people already know the answer
to this question and it's completely
absurd
and also if you were you wouldn't
[ __ ] answer the question
um oh my god
jesus i just visualized that
[ __ ] all right uh
you know what i was thinking of was was
that that [ __ ] movie jacob's ladder
when that thing in the tub
or was that from the shining oh my god
jesus christ all right we loved our son
can we bury him in our backyard so we
can always be close to him
all right that's a dumb question but
it's also a loving question the back of
the day you could do that
we actually buried this guy in his
backyard like some frontier trail of
tears [ __ ]
i did not even know this was legal until
i was asked this
and had to find out about it i guess you
can in that state not only did we bury
him
but they did not like the vault we had
ordered him and made us come back the
next day and take him out of the hole to
put in
a sealed vault so he would not get wet
um oh my god these are crazy
all right brace yourself for this one
number three
can you cut off my wife's favorite
tattoo on her left leg and can i keep it
sorry jeffrey dahmer we can't do that
for you
i know this is my grandmother's funeral
but can i
but can i have your number hey look at
you get a little action there
this one was rather recent i am single
and somewhat attractive male
you got to be dude if you're getting her
[ __ ] all
her motor running in there dude but i
can tell you right now that chick is a
psycho
or has a big heart and doesn't judge
people i don't know
but i on the g i i think i covered all
the bases there
that's like that jerk off that [ __ ]
plays roulette and hits all the numbers
and then jumps up and down like he won
um this one was rather recent i'm a
single and somewhat attractive male
but i am very professional would never
poke pick up women at work or at a
funeral
literally this was a live episode of
funeral crashers if it was a show
my condolences to your dead grandmother
and family
that you clearly don't give a [ __ ] about
but i give her my number
but i did give her my number needless to
say oops
yeah what the [ __ ] um
she's probably some freak that wants to
[ __ ] in a coffin
watch that'll be the third date um this
this one was a comment i received from a
holy man
from a southwest asian culture
um a holy man of his religion came up to
me and said i only have one prayer to
say during
today's service i said okay oh okay
great not a problem
uh yes it's three hours long i was
stunned
and stared at him in silence only to
find out he was serious
i have tons of other stories i would
love to tell you
um if you find what i wrote interesting
i absolutely did and i am sure
myself as well as other funeral
professionals have tons of craziness
that they can write and tell you about
every troll in the public wants to be a
funeral director
and do my job until we are called out at
three in the morning to remove a
decomposed body in a [ __ ] house
i don't think everybody wants to be a
funeral director i hope you and your
family stay healthy
and and safe that's so creepy to hear
that yeah i don't want to see you buddy
during
this um yeah let me hear from the
funeral directors i want to hear some
more stories of [ __ ] weirdos
[Music]
i